.
>> EMILY, I WAS STUNNED WHEN I
SAW THIS EXCHANGE LAST NIGHT,
WOW, FIRST SAYING, YEAH, I
HAVEN'T GONE TO EUROPE AND NOW
SAYING, I'M NOTS FINISHED.
DOES SHE KNOW HOW TO
COMMUNICATE?
SHE'S TAKING MEDIA TRAINING, I
DO NOT THINK IT IS WORKING.
>> Emily: I DON'T SEE IT WORKING
YET EITHER, KAYLEIGH.
UNIVISION REPORTER DEMONSTRATED
MORE POISE AND STRENGTH AND
UNFLAPPABLE QUALITY THAN OUR
VICE PRESIDENT DID, TO THAT END,
I'M EMBARRASSED FOR HER,
CONSTITUENT, FOR HER TO LOSE HER
MIND EVERYONE SOMEBODY ASKS WHAT
SHE PERCEIVES AS A TOUGH
QUESTION OR DARES TO INTERJECT,
A TON OF T-SHIRTS MADE, I'M
SPEAKING, IT RINGS LIKE SHE'S A
MANIAC IN THESE INTERVIEWS.
TO GO BACK TO THE EARLIER
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW CRITICISM
IS FRAMED, LET'S READ A QUOTE
FROM EDWARD ISAAC DOVER, HARRIS'
AIDES BELIEVE THE REPUBLICANS
WHO ATTACK ON IMMIGRATION ARE
DOING SO BECAUSE A, THEY ARE
HAVING TROUBLE LANDING PUNCHES
ON BIDEN AND HARRIS IS A BLACK
WOMAN AND THEY WANT TO DAMAGE
HER AHEAD OF INEVITABLE RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
BIDEN SEES CRITICISMS IN SIMILAR
LIGHT, I GUESS IT IS NOT
POSSIBLE SHE IS SIMPLY FAILING
AT SOMETHING AND CRITICISM FALLS
SQUARELY WITHIN THAT AND YES,
YOU WOULD THINK AFTER 18 YEARS
OF HOLDING AN ESHG LECTED
POSITION, SHE WOULD DO BETTER IN
TOUGH INTERVIEWS.
>> Emily: GILLIAN, THE VICE
PRESIDENT STAFF TOLD REPORTERS
THEY ARE FRUSTRATED BY THE
QUESTIONING THINKING LESTER
HOLT'S QUESTION WAS GROUNDED IN
REPUBLICAN CRITICISM, IN FACT IT
WAS A FAIR QUESTION, BEYOND WHAT
THEY ARE TELLING REPORTERS,
THERE ARE WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
GONE ON BACKGROUND SAYING THEY
ARE PERPLEXED, TOLD CNN THIS,
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S INABILITY
TO ANSWER A QUESTION.
IT IS FASCINATING TO SEE THIS
KIND OF LEAKING AGAINST THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> Gillian: IT IS AND KAYLEIGH,
THE BEST THING ANYONE SAID CAME
FROM DANA A COUPLE DAYS AGO,
DANA PERINO SAID THE BIG PICTURE
PROBLEM HERE IS NOT A PR ISSUE,
NOT A COMMUNICATIONS ISSUE,
THERE IS UNDERLYING POLICY
PROBLEM AND UNTIL THE POLICY IS
REFINED AND UNTIL THE
ADMINISTRATION IS UNIFIED AROUND
SECURING THE BORDER, WHICH THEY
APPEAR TO NOT BE, MESSAGE
INL
REMAIN TRICKY, IT WILL REMAIN
AWKWARD.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO GO
ON DEFENSE BECAUSE UNDERLYING
REALITY SEEMS TO BE THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT ARE
NOT ON THE SAME PAGE ENTIRELY ON
THIS ISSUE.
THEY DON'T AGREE ON WHETHER OR
NOT IT IS A BIG DEAL CRIE
CRID
DON'T AGREE HOW TO ADDRESS IT,
THAT IS POLICY CHALLENGE.
UNTIL YOU GET AT THE ROOT CAUSE
HERE, WELL, NO PUN INTENDED, GET
AT THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION POLICY PROBLEM,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO FIX WHAT
WE'RE SEE OG TV, WHICH IS
UNCOMFORTABLE TO WATCH.
>> Kayleigh: DANA IS RIGHT, THEY
HAVE A POLICY PROBLEM, SUBSTAN
PROBLEM, NOT MESSAGING ONE.
CLAY, THE MEDIA IS NOTICING HOW
BAD THIS TRIP WAS.
I HAVE HEADLINES I WANT TO PUT
ON THE SCREEN.
WE DON'T OFTEN SEE CRITICISM
LIKE THIS.
CNN, KAMALA HARRIS FIRST ROCKY
TRIP.
POLITICO, TRIP SHOWED HER
WEAKNESS AND HARRIS' TRIP TO
GUATEMALA AND MEXICO IS MIX OF
DIPLOMACY AND CONTROVERSY,
INTERESTING TO SEE THE MEDIA
TAKING NOTICE.
>> Clay: YEAH, THE MOST SHOCKING
THING ABOUT THE CLIP OF KAMALA
HARRIS ON THE SECOND INTERVIEW,
KAYLEIGH, YOU WOULD KNOW BETTER
THAN ANYBODY, SHE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PREPPED TO FINALLY ANSWER
THIS QUESTION.
MAYBE SHE WASN'T EXPECTING IT
WHEN LESTER HOLT CAUGHT HER
UNAWARE AND SHE MADE THE COMMENT
ABOUT NOT HAVING BEEN TO EUROPE,
FAILURE SHE CREATED HERSELF.
WHEN YOU MADE THAT ERROR, EXPECT
TO GET QUIZZED ON IT AND HAVE
PERFECT RESPONSE AT YOUR READY,
THAT IS WHY YOU ARE SEEING
OFFICIALS LEAKING, I'M SURE THEY
PREPPED HER AND SHE FAILED
AGAIN.
THE BIG PICTURE STORY HERE, THEY
ARE TRYING TO AVOID GOING TO THE
BORDER BECAUSE THERE ISN'T A
GOOD ANSWER FOR WHY THE BORDER
IS FALLING APARTS AND IF SHE
GOES THERE, ALL OF THE MEDIA
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN WILLING TO
PRETEND THIS WAS NOT AN ISSUE,
WAS NOT A CRISIS WILL GET ON THE
AIRPLANE, FLY THERE WITH HER AND
ALL HAVE TO WRITE STORIES ABOUT
WHAT A MESS THE BORDER IS.
SHE CAN'T COMMUNICATE VERY WELL
AND HAS LOOMING BORDER CRISIS
SHE'S IN CHARGE OF, THIS FEELS
LIKE TO ME, A MUSHROOM CLOUD
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO GROW AND
FOLLOW HER AND I DON'T THINK IT
IS ABOUT RACE AT ALL, IT IS
ABOUT INCOMPETENCE, SHE'S
DEMONSTRATED GREAT DEAL OF OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS.
>> NO DOUBT HER AIDS PREPPED
HER, THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THE PRINCIPAL, WHO HAS BEEN IN
THE PUBLIC LIGHT FOR SOMETIME,
BUT DOES NOT SEEM READY FOR
PRIME TIME.
TOMI, THIS COMES AT TIME THE
BORDER IS ON FIRE, 180,000
ENCOUNTERS LAST MONTH, 21-YEAR
HIGH, 40,000 FOR INDIVIDUALS
OUTSIDE OF CENTRAL AMERICA, WOW,
THEY HAVE A LOT ON THEIR HANDS.
>> Tomi: YEAH, WHEN KAMALA
HARRIS SAYS SHE WANT TO ADDRESS
THE ROOT CAUSE OR SEE THE
PROBLEM OF WHY PEOPLE ARE COMING
TO THE BORDER.
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM, IT IS IN
FRONT OF US, VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS A WHOLE.
WE KNOW WHY PEOPLE ARE COMING.
THE FACT DEMOCRATS SIT BACK LIKE
THEY ARE DUMBFOUNDED PEOPLE ARE
POURING ACROSS THE BORDER IS
AMAZING THEY CAN SIT THERE AND
SAY THAT WITH A STRAIGHT FACE.
THEY SAID IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, WE ARE NOT GOING TO TURN
PEOPLE AWAY.
PEOPLE ARE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER WITH BIDEN SHIRTS ON.
WE KNOW WHAT THE ROOT CAUSES
ARE, THEY ARE THE ROOT CAUSES.
THE END OF THE DAY, INSTEAD OF
ASKING WHEN SHE'S GOING TO THE
BORDER, I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF
ANY TIME SOON, THEY HAVE TO ASK,
WHY ARE YOU NOT GOING TODAY?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING THAT IS SO
MUCH MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF OUR NATION, WHY
IS IT YOU ARE AVOIDING IT?
IT DOESN'T JUST NEED TO BE WHEN,
IT HAS TO BE WHY.
CLAY MENTIONED, DEMOCRATS WILL
HAVE TO CONFRONT THE UGLY TRUTH
THEY DO NOT CARE PEOPLE ARE
POURING ACROSS THE BORDER, THEY
DON'T CARE OUR COUNTRY IS BEING
INVADED AND HAVING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF NEW PEOPLE COMING
IN AT TIME WE ARE PICKING UP
PIECES FROM THE PANDEMIC.
THEY DON'T CARE, IT IS NOT A
CRISIS TO THEM, IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY, BUT THEY CAN'T SAY
THAT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
FOR NOW, DOG AND PONY SHOW, THE
QUESTION NEEDS TO BE ASKED WHY,
KAMALA HARRIS, WHY WON'T YOU GO?
>> Kayleigh: SHE IS BUSY
SECURING F